Good morning, Hank. It's Sunday. Bonus video!
So an opinion poll last week found that
more than 20% of Americans believe that the President of the United States,
Barack Obama,
is a Muslim.
Now Obama has repeatedly said that he is a Christian,
but he also repeatedly said he'd allow us to import prescription drugs from Canada
and that hasn't happened.
So instead of taking Obama's word that he is not a Muslim,
I thought today we could do an analysis
of what we know about Barack Obama
and what we know about Islam
and come to our own conclusions.
So the five most central facets of Islamic belief and practice are known as the "Five Pillars of Islam."
The first is the "Shahada",
the recitation and belief in the statement that
"There is no deity other than God and that Muhammad is God's prophet."
You're not a Muslim until you say and believe the shahada.
We can't prove the president Obama has ever said the shahada,
but we also can't prove that he hasn't said it.
So let's move on.
The second pillar is prayer.
Now as many of us know, observant Muslims pray at least five times a day:
dawn, noon, mid-afternoon, sunset and night time.
And it just so happens that we know a lot about Barack Obama's daily schedule
because he's the President.
So, for instance, we know that on April  8th 2010,
during evening prayers,
Obama was having dinner with Dmitry Medvedev,
who you will be surprised to learn did not emerge from that dinner saying,
"Oh my God,
Barack Obama pulled out a prayer rug,
turned it in the direction of the Kaaba and proceeded to pray."
We also know that on April 5th 2010,
during noon prayers,
Barack Obama was hosting the White House Easter Egg Hunt.
Nobody at that event noted Barack Obama
prostrate on the ground praying in Arabic.
The third pillar of Islam is "Zakāt".
Zakāt is almsgiving;  Muslims are required to give 2.5% of their wealth every year to the poor.
The public has access to a lot of Obama's tax returns
and between 2000 and 2005,
he and Michelle gave an average of less than
1% of their income to charity.
Meaning that, in addition to being a bit of a tightwad,
Barack Obama was not performing zakāt.
The fourth pillar is "Sawm" or fasting.
During the holy month of Ramadan, Muslims do not eat or drink
between dawn and dusk.
Ramadan began this year on August 11th.
On August 17th, a photographer snapped this picture
of Barack Obama ordering lunch,
which he proceeded to eat in front of hundreds of people.
In fact,
the president has been seen eating and drinking during the day,
pretty much every single day of Ramadan.
The fifth pillar is "Hajj" or pilgrimage.
Muslims who can afford to do so and are able-bodied are obligated to make the pilgrimage to Mecca,
at least once in their lives.
Obama has not yet made this trip.
Although here's still time.
But it's unlikely he ever will for this reason:
the Saudi government will not let you into Mecca
if you are not a Muslim
and Barack Obama is not a Muslim.
So while it's possible that Barack Obama has said Shahada
at some private moment that we don't know about,
he completely and spectacularly fails to follow any of the other four pillars of Islam.
So we don't even have to get into the fact that he drinks beer
and eats pork hotdogs,
humorously.
This means one of two possibilities:
Hank, either President Obama is not a Muslim,
or he is a really bad Muslim.
Of course, there's nothing wrong with being a Muslim;
President Obama just isn't one.
He's also not Jewish,
not a baby
and not the starting left fielder for the New York Yankees.
So Drudge Report, Huffington Post, CNN, Fox News,
maybe we can find something else to talk about.
Hank, I'll see you tomorrow.
Oh and PS.
this suit-
it isn't all business.